قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم حمله
مداهمه وتفتيشات تخللت اعتقالات ومواجهات
في بعض مدن الضفه الغربيه وفي نابلس اقتحم
الجيش الاسرائيلي ليله الماضيه المدينه
واظهرت لقطات مصوره بثتها منصات وحسابات
محليه الفلسطينيه لحظه اقتحام عربات
الاحتلال احياء المدينه سمعت اصوات
اشتباكات مسلحه مع مسلحين فلسطينيين
هذا وقال نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان قوه
الاحتلال اعتقلت سته عشر فلسطينيين على
الاقل خلال حملات الدعم من جانبها اعلنت
مجموعه عرين الاسود في بيان لها عن تصدي
عناصرها لقوات الاحتلال في المنطقه
الغربيه لمدينه نابلس
في غضون ذلك اقدم عدد من المستوطنين على
اعطاب مركبات لفلسطينيين وكتابه شعارات
معاديه في قريه برقا جنوب شرق مدينه رام
الله وفضى شود عيان من قريه برقاب بان
مجموعه من المستوطنين تسللت الى القريه
فجرا وقامت باعطاب اطارات ثمان مركبات
تعود لمواطننا فلسطينيين